been at uber for about four years and
there I have
a couple of teams including our natural
language and conversational AI efforts
are anomaly detection team and
forecasting platformer teams in addition
to that I lead a couple of other data
science teams as outlined on the slides
before joining Ober I was a postdoc at
Caltech working on approximate quantum
dynamics in order to study complex
biological systems such as enzymatic
reactions I would like to give a huge
shout out to the cross functional and
cross organizational teams that are
deeply involved in building our natural
language and conversational AI efforts
at uber in particular I would like to
thank two individuals shown on the
right-hand side of the slide who are the
active contributors to the work that I'm
going to present today so what are the
key takeaways from today's talk well
firstly at uber we have dozens of
natural language and conversational AI
use cases and if you're interested in
working in this domain please feel free
to come and see me over lunch we're very
actively hiring in this space secondly
we not only have use cases but we're
also already actively employing and
using natural language and
conversational AI in order to improve
the user experience and so today I will
go in detail into two of these use cases
on the left hand side you can see the so
called custom obsession ticket assistant
this is where we use natural language
processing in combination with machine
learning in order to empower our
customer service representatives and
provide an enhanced customer experience
to our end consumers and then on the
right-hand side you can see the
so-called one-click chat this is a
recent feature that we launched which
allows driver partners to respond to
incoming messages from riders in the app
at a push of a button in the final part
of my talk I will be addressing some of
the core components that are recurring
within conversational AI systems and in
combination with the large number of use
cases that we have at uber this really
lends itself very well to platform is a
ssin so let's get started with the first
use case
as I mentioned this is coda the custom
obsession ticket assistant and as
mentioned in the previous slide we use
here combination of natural language
processing and machine learning
technologies in order to provide an
enhanced customer support experience now
whilst this is a specific use case and
potentially specific to Ober there are
some general key learnings we can take
away from this use case and these are
threefold firstly deep learning
methodologies have been found to be
extremely useful in this space and often
outperform the traditional employed
methodologies in the case of coda we'll
see that natural length or deep learning
natural language methodologies
outperform the traditional ones for over
20 percent now that being said if your
company has not yet invested in deep
learning infrastructures the traditional
methodologies still provide a very solid
first starting point and I'm going to
address both the traditional
methodologies we have investigated and
deployed as well as those in the deep
learning space in the following slides
and then finally as everyone knows in
this room model accuracy is not
everything and also here with this
particular use case we have to make a
trade-off between model accuracy as well
as speed of computational inference as
well as training so why would we want to
invest in such a customer service
representative assistant there are two
areas here one is that we have a very
large volume of tickets we get millions
of support tickets every week from our
writers drivers eaters kurz freighters
etc so a pure scale is one aspect but
then there's also the complexity we have
thousands of different issue types and
this complexity only increases as we add
new lines of businesses for example
scooters and bikes so let's delve a
little bit more deeply into what such a
customer service flow looks like first
the user who has a question or
encounters an issue would be navigating
with
in the app or in our web application to
the help page and then submits a support
ticket this is often accompanied by a
couple of sentences around the
description of what the issue is now
then the customer service representative
receives this income and ticket and
needs to do three major things firstly
they need to figure out what the actual
issue type is as in how this issue that
the customer has described maps into the
so called contact type tree which is the
collection of all the issue types that
we have then secondly they want to
understand whether an action might have
to be taken so for example an issue type
might be a cancellation and an action
might be an appeasement that the
customer service representative can give
and then finally we want to close this
out by responding to the user has
written in and here the customer service
representative can pull from thousands
of different reply templates and use
these as a starting point for their
response now this all seems very
straightforward but if we go a level
deeper and actually look what the
customer service representative needs to
do here then we can see this is a quite
complex and non straightforward task and
this goes to a little bit what I alluded
to earlier in terms of the complexity we
have thousands of different contact
types that are arranged in a contact
type tree which can be quite deep
between three and six layers we have
several actions that the customer
representative needs to choose from and
then finally there are thousands of
potential reply templates that they can
draw from so based of this we saw the
opportunity of using machine learning
methodologies in order to empower our
customer service representatives to
provide high quality customer support at
scale and to dynamically adjust to
incoming volumes and ticket types so
coda basically what does it do it takes
the incoming support ticket and then
understands what the intent of the
customer is it uses a lot of the meta
information as well then provides
suggested contact types actions as well
the three most relevant reply templates
to the customer support agent and then
they can choose to use these or not
so let's look delve a little bit more
deeply into the models that we were
using for this customer service
representative I will be starting off
outlining the traditional approaches
that we use and then subsequently we're
going to delve into the deep learning
approaches so for the first iteration of
coda we built a traditional NLP pipeline
in combination with a random forest we
used for different types of feature
feature types here ranging from the user
information to trip information metadata
around the tickets as well as the ticket
message itself now using these features
can be very advantageous because it
reduces greatly the potential reply and
contact type space to give you a
concrete example if we know that a
ticket is coming from a driver partner
we can immediately exclude any issue
types that would be submitted from
writers for example now unsurprisingly
the incoming message from the user
itself is being found to be the most
important feature within within this
model and so in this case we used a
traditional NLP pipeline which consisted
of pre-processing such as tokenization
or stop word removal to yield a bag of
words and then we utilized topic
modeling on top of this bag of words in
order to extract the intent of the
customer now here we use two different
approaches we use tf-idf for a low level
and opie feature extraction and latent
semantic analysis for a high level
feature extraction now we then take all
of these features and pass them through
a multi-class classification algorithm
in this case a random forest to yield
the top three contact types as well as
top three replied templates framing this
as a multi-class classification problem
seemed the first natural thing to do but
what we realized is the model accuracy
was not quite where we wanted it to be
so therefore
we pivoted the approach to a binary
classification with point-wise ranking
methodology and we also introduced class
prototypes for each specific reply
template as well as contact type a
specimen so to say that we got from
historic data we then used the output
and the score from the binary
classification for the ranking again to
obtain the top three contact types and
top three reply templates now this
approach was 25 percent more accurate
than the multi-class classification
approach an addition also provided much
faster training times
so given this success we then went ahead
productionize this model and rent some a
B tests and we were very excited to see
an eight point eight percent reduction
in the average handle time which
directly means that the customer can get
their tickets resolved much faster and
very very importantly we didn't see any
reduction in the customer satisfaction
score by deploying this model now this
model is live for multiple different
languages including English Spanish and
Portuguese and covers over 90% of our
ticket volume now as I mentioned earlier
deep learning methodologies have been
very dominant in the natural language
and conversational AI space and so we
want to also test whether deep learning
approaches could be beneficial to this
customer obsession ticket assistant to
this end we evaluated six different text
encoding models these differ by two
major things the first thing whether we
use word or character based approaches
now character based approaches can be
very good if you have misspellings or
out of vocabulary words we also had both
character convolutional neural networks
or recurrent neural networks as well
across these six approaches and as you
can see on the far right we have also
hybrids between these two as well now
recurrent neural networks obviously can
very nicely capture the sequential May
of the incoming texts on the other hand
CNN's tend to be much faster so let's
look at the outcome of comparing these
six different models for our particular
use case as you can see the Hybrid CNN
RNN method based on characters was the
one with highest test accuracy now as
you can also see it was by far the most
expensive so this basically then meant
that when we went to productionize this
model we went with the second-best model
in terms of test accuracy the word CNN
option now whilst we still went with the
second-best this still gave us a huge
lift over our traditional methods we saw
over 20 percent improvement over the
random forest method that I described
earlier earlier we then improved the
model further to encapsulate some of the
hierarchy from the contact type tree as
I mentioned in the introduction all of
these issue types are assembled in a
tree and so we wanted to make sure that
we could capture the path from the root
node down all the way to the leaf node
as part of our model instead of just
predicting the contact type
independently and this obviously would
also give us gains in terms of the model
accuracy so the way that we accomplished
this was to use a recurrent decoder
where we used as input the the top node
of the of the tree and then basically
fed it in to yield the child node as the
output which we then fed in again etc
etc until we ended up at the leaf leaf
node so as I mentioned the advantage
here is to get higher model accuracy but
much much more importantly it provided a
much better user experience to our
customer support representatives if the
model was wrong because in this case if
the model is wrong we're still typically
ending up very in a similar space in
terms of the contact type tree of where
the agent wants to be and they're only
one or two clicks away from the actual
solution versus if we do not employ this
we can end up in a very distant space on
the contact type tree and it's very hard
for the customer service representative
to return
so let's in summary step back and look
at the final architecture that is shown
on this slide we already went in depth
about how we encoded the text features
via convolutional layers as you saw from
CUDA v1 there were a lot of other
features that we wanted to incorporate
in this model that gave a lot of signal
these were categorical features which we
encoded using embedding layers numerical
features that were encoded using
batchelomez ation layers and then of
course we also included binary features
for example is the trip completed or not
and then we concatenated all of these
together and fed them through fully
connected layers with dropout in order
to obtain the contact type we utilize
the recurrent Dakota that I showed you
on the previous slide and then in order
to get the reply we use the softmax
classification and importantly here we
also inputted the type as as an input
feature as well and that of course also
helps us again to increase the accuracy
of the model because once you know what
the issue type is for example
cancellation you can immediately reduce
your contact type space in terms of the
reply accordingly and know that you only
need to focus on reply templates that
are related to cancellations now
obviously when we train we use the
ground truth type data in order to
inform the reply and when it comes to
the testing we use the predicted contact
type in order to predict the reply so
this completes concludes the overview of
the cosmo obsession ticket assistant and
I will be pivoting now and talking about
the second use case our one-click chat
occ use case as mentioned earlier here
we're utilizing natural language and
conversational AI in order to assist
driver partners in quickly replying to
incoming messages from the writers and
here we will see two things one is that
semantic understanding is extremely
important and the second thing
we will be showing how we can use a very
small set of labelled examples in order
to be very effective in this intense
discovery so let's reframe this problem
in the lens of natural language so as
previously seen in the coda example the
first step is to take an incoming
message and to map it into an attempt so
for example the writer might be saying
where are you right now and then we want
to map this to the topic of where are
you now contrary to the previous example
we didn't know what the potential Rider
and Driver topics were that people were
talking about so as part of this project
we also have to first do intent
discovery as well once you actually have
to intend it's very straightforward to
go to a reply we have some preset
replies for every single intent that we
discover and then we basically surface
this in the driver app for the driver
partner to select so there are quite a
lot of challenges associated with this
project the first one is that the
message is very short it often contains
typos and abbreviations as you can see
here from real data on the left-hand
side and autocomplete is often not our
friend as you can see at the bottom we
have here sentence I'm Washington for
you which clearly should be saying I'm
waiting for you so whatever methodology
we use it needs to be able to
disentangle this as well some of the
other you know challenges that we might
be facing on this front are that we have
perhaps different words but with very
similar meaning as shown in the middle
column and then on the very right hand
side you might have a lot of
similarities in the words between these
two sentences but they actually have
very different meaning in the context
that we're talking about here so as seen
in the previous slide we need to be able
to capture the semantic understanding
extremely well and in order to do this
we use the unsupervised learning
methodology dok2 Veck this is an
expansion of word Tuvok where Tuvok
basically allows you to come up with
word embeddings dr. Vivek allows you to
come up with things like sentence or
paragraph document and
when you employ it so we basically use
millions of English uber chat data and
they basically ran it through the dr.
vex model now let me show you what this
looks like here we see at isni plot of
some of these sentence embeddings that
we got as you can see we get some really
really nice clusters here of various
different topics that writers and
drivers are conversing about that our
data scientists then labeled so this
brings me to the next challenge which is
obviously that these clusters are come
out unlabeled in nature and so we
basically hand labeled a couple of
thousand examples too then basically
determine what these clusters actually
mean and what the topics of conversation
are the rest is pretty straightforward
we calculate centroids of each of these
intent clusters and then this concludes
the training phase whenever we have an
incoming message done at run time we
calculate the distance between this
message and the intent cluster centroid
and then we assign it to the nearest
cluster so with this we basically
conclude the intent detection and
discovery phase of this project and as I
mentioned in the introduction the reply
retrieval is merely a lookup of
potential responses that have been
predetermined so now let's go back to
the original example the real-world
example that I showed you
i'm washington for you and actually when
we utilize this approach they're just
shooting the previous slides it
correctly identifies that Washington
should be waiting and so there is a big
advantage that we have from actually
using our data and building the sentence
embeddings ourselves as it can be can
pick up the context within our ecosystem
so next I want to give you a glimpse of
what the future looks like of one click
chat we obviously want to not only
provide text modalities but also whose
new message from musi I'm waiting by the
Starbucks do you want me to respond tell
you see I'll be right there
ok sure ready to send it send it
great message then so these new features
that we're building will allow driver
partners to also provide answers to the
writers using their voice which is very
exciting and in my final part I want to
tell you a little bit about the building
blocks that many conversational AI
systems have in common and as I
mentioned in the introduction the
combination of having a large number of
use cases at uber for natural language
and conversational AI with the fact that
a lot of this is abstract about really
lends itself well to platform ization so
in the previous examples we have seen
that we really need to understand the
intent so basically the topic of
conversation of the end user and so this
is typically handled by a semantic
parser on this front now so far we have
only seen single turn conversations so
one incoming message one response you
would probably want to evolve this to a
multi turn conversation with a back and
forth and here the dialog manager comes
into play who for example tracks the
state of the conversation and then
finally we want to move from a semantic
representation which is not human
understandable back into something that
can be consumed by a human being and
here the language generator comes into
play we are actively building such a
natural language conversational AI
platform at uber and we're actually
using some of the latest cutting-edge
technologies and not only that we're
actively working with our counterparts
in our AI labs or research division to
push the envelope on these methodologies
as well and so if you want to learn more
whether it's about the applications that
I've shown you today or about the new
developments that we're doing in this
space we have several blog posts on our
uber inch blog we have a recent paper at
kdd and we have two submissions for nips
where we're also going to talk about
some of the multi-turn conversationally
I
and devar's that we have been starting
and with this I would like to thank you
very much for your attention and if you
have any questions and happy to discuss
them over lunch thank you very much
[Applause]